-Wow, wow.
-Welcome to the show.
I am so happy you're here.
You look sharp, as always.
-Thank you. Likewise.
-You know, I am such a big fan
of your work for a long time.
I've known you,
and I've always run into you.
You're always a nice guy to me
and everything.
And I got to say, you did this
"Searching for Italy:
Stanley Tucci" on CNN.
I loved it so much.
I freaked out.
I -- It's -- I want to get into
all of the details.
But I loved everything.
I loved the episode
with the hailstorm.
-Oh, yeah.
-When everyone was locked in.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-But then I felt inspired.
I felt like I became,
like, inspired.
I should be a chef.
-Yeah.
-And I felt like, "If Stanley
is telling me what to do..."
I thought through the TV,
you're talking to me
and saying, "Jimmy, go out
and make a pizza yourself."
-Yes, yeah. Yeah.
-"Don't just microwave a pizza.
Go make it yourself."
-Yes, do it yourself.
-So I did it.
And I did it -- I made it.
I was inspired.
I put it on -- on YouTube.
-Yes.
-Because I was inspired.
I wanted to show
other people how --
that I know how to do it.
-Yes.
-And, of course, Jimmy Kimmel,
who really knows
a lot about pizza...
-Yes.
-...just destroyed my video.
-Yeah. Yeah.
He's -- he's tough. He's tough.
-He -- No, he really knows
his pizza, by the way.
And he was just like --
He e-mailed me before he did it.
He goes, "Dude, what?
I got to respond to this thing.
This is insane."
And I go -- 'Cause I was like --
I was rolling it.
-Yeah.
-With a roller.
And he said,
"Don't ever do that."
-No.
-No, no, I didn't know.
-No -- Yeah.
-Yeah, it was just every single
mistake I could ever make.
-But he's --
But he's sort of beyond --
He's not -- I mean --
-He's not normal, is he?
-I've eaten pizza at his house.
-No, he's --
-And it's -- it's incredible.
-No, he takes it
to the next level.
-No, and I can't
make pizza like that.
No, he's -- I'm not kidding.
He really is amazing.
-I think you inadvertently
restarted the late-night wars.
[ Laughter ]
That's just it.
Just by that pizza thing.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But I -- I saw this --
-I felt there
was something lacking.
-Yeah, thank you.
You're always --
You're always spicing up life.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-I love that.
-Yeah.
-But you've inspired people
to -- to travel and to cook.
It's a big deal.
In Italy,
I've read these articles
where people are having
Stanley Tucci tours.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-That must feel good, right?
-Yeah, it feels great.
I mean, I'd love a piece
of the action, but, you know...
-No, no, no.
Yeah, you can't do that.
-No, no, I can't do that.
No, but it's wonderful.
It -- Well, you know, look, when
the show came out, we were --
You know, it was during,
you know, the pandemic.
-Sure. Of course.
-During lockdown.
So we had a captive audience,
right?
And people were desperate
to get out.
And they sort of
lived vicariously through us.
-You won two Emmys for it.
-Yes.
-For "Searching for Italy."
Two Emmys.
-Yes, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-Well-deserved.
-Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
-Will there be a season three?
-Yes, I hope there will be.
Unfortunately, CNN has canceled
all of their
original programming,
so hopefully we'll end up
on another streamer, network.
We don't know.
-Wow.
-But, yes, I have plans to do
season three and more.
-So, "Searching for Italy"
is searching for a new network.
-Searching --
Searching for a network.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
Not as appetizing.
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
I just love that you did that.
And then I love that.
And then you also posted
something on Instagram.
-Yeah.
-Of you making a cocktail.
A Negroni.
And it went viral beyond belief.
-Yes, I know.
-You -- Yeah, and I was like,
"This is -- This is everything.
Stanley Tucci is owning
the world right now."
We loved it. It was so good.
I mean, did you know that
you were going to go that --
-No, no.
-You're just making it for fun?
-No, I did it --
I did it because --
I did it for my agency
in England, Curtis Brown.
My wife works there.
-Yeah.
-And she said, "Make a cocktail
for everybody during lockdown.
It'd be really nice.
And, you know, people --
cheer them up."
-Yeah.
-So I did that.
And then she said, "Well,
put it on your Instagram."
And then she showed me
how to do that.
[ Laughter ]
And then I did it.
-Yeah.
-And then that happened.
-And then Chris Evans tweeted
it or re-something'ed it.
-Oh, yeah.
-And then it went
completely crazy.
-Yeah, Chris Evans.
That's right. He loved it.
-Chris Evans.
Anything he touches. Yeah.
-Turns to gold, yeah.
-It's true, yeah.
-But the big hot drink now
is Negroni sbagliatos.
-Sbagliato, yes.
-Sbagliato.
With prosecco in it.
-It's all over TikTok.
-Yeah.
-And I don't -- I just --
I have two made here tonight.
-Oh, wow. What do you know?
-I did not make these.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought maybe we could
have a taste test.
'Cause when you do a Negroni,
just -- you do a normal Negroni.
Is that correct?
-I do, I do.
But I -- I like mine up,
as opposed to on the rocks,
the Negroni.
But you wouldn't necessarily
do that with this.
-Okay, okay.
-Yeah.
-Cheers. Let's try this
and see how it tastes.
Me and Stanley Tucci
trying a Negroni sbagliato
with prosecco in it.
[ Jazz music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I'd buy that for a dollar.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's --
-That's pretty tasty.
-That's nice. It wants --
-It tastes a little
champagne-y to me.
-It's a little too champagne-y.
-Prosecco-y. Yeah.
-Prosecco-y, yeah.
It should have a little more
of the harder alcohols in it.
-Right?
-Yeah, I think so.
-I agree. I think, yeah.
-It really just needs,
like, a little --
It needs to be graced with it.
-Yeah.
I think cheers, but this is --
I'm going to go with original
Stanley Tucci Negroni.
Yeah, if you're going to go --
Yeah.
That's what I would go with.
This came out. This went viral.
And then
here you go on the list.
You're one of the sexiest
bald men on the planet.
And --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go. Number two.
I don't know if you could --
I'm underneath --
-Barely, barely.
-Barely.
-6.3. Yeah.
-Barely there, yeah.
But, hey,
there's always next year, bud.
-Right.
There's always next year. Yes.
-You're just crushing it
right now.
-Yeah, oh, thank you.
-I want to talk to you about
the Whitney Houston movie.
-Yeah.
-Gosh, it's beautiful.
It's heartbreaking.
But you play
a legendary producer.
-Yeah.
-Record legend Clive Davis
who discovered Whitney Houston.
-Yeah.
-Who is an actual
living real person.
-Yes, still.
-Is it hard to play someone
who is actually next to you
and go like,
"Well, that's really --
This is how I would do it"?
-No. Luckily, he wasn't on
the set when I was filming.
-Good, good, good.
-That would've been
disconcerting.
He was -- I talked to him.
I saw the documentary about him.
I read his book.
And then we had a Zoom call.
I was filming in Turin.
I was doing the episode
of Piemonte.
And he -- we talked for an hour,
and he was amazing.
And then I met him for,
like, a half-hour before --
like, two days
before I started filming.
And he was nothing
but generous and kind.
And he's fascinating.
We listened to --
The music we listen to today,
one of the reasons
is because of him.
-Yes.
-It's amazing.
And this is a guy
who was a lawyer
and ended up in this job
sort of by happenstance.
-Yeah.
-And as it turns out,
he's not a singer.
He's not a musician.
He's not a --
It turns out he just has
this incredible ear...
-Yeah.
-...that now has informed
all of our ears.
-Yeah, you're right.
-Yeah.
-And who's playing
Whitney Houston again?
-Naomi Ackie.
This woman is -- This is
an extraordinary actress.
-Naomi Ackie. It's unbelievable.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Stanley Tucci in
"Whitney Houston:
I Wanna Dance with Somebody."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-♪ How will I know
if he's thinking of me? ♪
♪ I try to phone,
but I'm too shy ♪
-Maybe.
-Maybe? Why?
-♪ Falling in love
is so bittersweet ♪
♪ How will I know
if he really loves me? ♪
♪ I say a prayer
with every heartbeat ♪
You know?
I could do something
with the chorus.
Go up a key there,
get more out of it.
-Yeah, but that's not
a reason to -- to do a song.
It's gotta have a hook.
-A hook?
-Yeah.
-I'll give it a hook.
-Yeah. "I'll give it a hook."
Stanley Tucci, everybody.
We love you, buddy.
-Thank you.
-"Whitney Houston:
I Wanna Dance with Somebody"
is in theaters December 23rd.
We'll be right back with
Michael Che and Sean Patton.
Stick around.